all right good evening everybody uh
thanks for coming out um my name is uh
Dean kungl I'm an undergraduate student
here at Yale and I'd like to welcome you
to what can European history teach us
about Trump's America so I'll let you
know tonight that the lecture is being
recorded so there's no need for you to
do that it'll be posted on YouTube after
the fact the Yale political union the
European studies Council of my myself
are very proud to welcome uh Professor
Timothy Snider the author of Black Earth
the Holocaust as history and warning um
as a student in one of Professor
Snider's classes I can assure you that
we're all in for a treat tonight if you
could hold your questions till the end
uh there'll be a question and answer
session since this is an event mostly
for undergraduates um we will be
favoring questions for undergraduates
and microphones will be passed around so
thank you very much and enjoy the
talk
can you that could you that
one so if I just if I just blast it out
can you hear me does that work okay um
so what what I want to do in in the next
hour or so is is share with you an idea
about history and politics it's really
just one idea um the idea is that
history has to be political if I get
that idea across then what I will try to
do is give you a sense of how the 20th
century might just be useful for the
century that all of you or most of you
um will be will be confronting so let me
begin at the beginning with what seems
really simple but but it's not and that
is that is the question of how history
is political how history has to be
political I'm going to say some things
which will seem so simple that they'd be
more appropriate for elementary school
but it's been actually I shouldn't talk
down elementary school because like when
I when I go to my kids's first grade
parent teacher orientation and I listen
to his teaching philosophy the first
grade teachers I was like yeah that's
pretty much that's pretty much mine
he's a he's a little more eloquent so I
shouldn't I shouldn't talk down
shouldn't talk down elementary school
but the point is that some things that
are very simple I think have been
forgotten so history to have history you
have to have a sense of time with the
past right a past which is complex which
is composed of moments um a present
where things are somehow related to that
past but many things are still possible
and a future which is indeterminate but
which has something to do with that past
P now if you accept these premises the
idea that time flows forward that things
are indeterminate but nevertheless
inexplicable that there are moments we
can concentrate on and try to understand
then you're thinking historically now
why why would I claim that this is
somehow political well for one thing if
you think historically in so far as you
think historically you have a political
imagination right if you know about the
past you know that various things
happened right and to know that
something happened is to know that it
was possible and to know that something
is possible to actually see it in your
mind's eye is to have imagination and
more if you really understand a moment
of the past any moment of the past you
know that that past moment contains not
just what did happen but all the things
that might have happened right and in so
far as you can imagine those things
you've also developed a political
imagination and once you do that and
then then cast your Gaze on the present
and on the future you will be more
suspicious of ideas which say it has to
be this way it has to be that way right
you'll be suspicious of every monism
you'll be suspicious of every
determinism which suggests to you that
things have to be a certain way now um
another thing which is extraordinarily
nice about history is that and this is
again very conventional right so just
nod and humor me it means that nothing
is entirely old there is only one
history right I mean since writing began
and people began to contemplate written
sources and try to make sense of them
and put them together there has only
been one history we just have one
history everything is in some sense
connected even if we don't see all of
the connections which means that nothing
is entirely old right everything which
is in the past is somehow related to the
present the comforting part about that
the comforting part the rooting part the
grounding part about that is that
nothing is is entirely new either right
which isn't to say that history repeats
because it doesn't it doesn't even rhyme
although you know in general Mark
Twain's a genius it doesn't even rhyme
but nothing is entirely new right if you
think historically you can never be
completely surprised I mean you can be
surprised by certain things right like
I'm surprised sometimes by what people
wear in office hours early in the
morning but I'm never
completely
surprised right because I know that the
history of nudity is
old right so I'm never completely
surprised right you can so much less
blushing than there should be really I
mean in all fairness all right so but so
nothing is inti so you can never be
completely surprised there's always a
bit of you which says aha okay I'm
shocked but that reminds me of this okay
I'm surprised rised but I see I see a
certain I see a certain pattern right so
nothing is entirely new now I I hope
that what I've said thus far is
uncontroversial and sensible um and
legible you know at least to those of
you who who who who are working with me
together to do history but what I next
want to point out is that there are
other ways to think about time other
really powerful ways to think about time
ahistorical or rather antihist hisorical
ways to think about time and as I
describe them I I want you to see how
familiar they are and how they impinge
upon your lives how they're in fact
present all of the time one of them is
what I would call the politics of
inevitability and this is so close to us
so close to my generation but also to
yours even closer to yours that it
somehow it's it can be difficult to
extri oneself from it what's the
politics of inevitability the politics
of inevitability looks it looks a little
bit like history it has a sense of the
past it has a sense of the present it
has a sense of the future time moves
forward but in the politics of
inevitability we know where time is
moving right we know where it's going to
end up we're confident where it's going
to end up right in the case of the
politics of inevitability which has
Afflicted Us in the west and in
particular the United States in the last
25 years or so the notion is it's all
going to sort itself out into liberal
democracy one way or the other right so
I mean the the trademark of this ver of
this notion was the end of History right
so all that's left is liberal democracy
we don't have any other ideas this is
such a fcy we have no other ideas
therefore history must be moving towards
liberal democracy okay it sounds
ridiculous when I put it that way but
that's been your whole life right that's
been your whole life up to now right
that's the politics of inevitability
feels like history it looks like history
smart people can defend it as history
and and have done so right but what is
it in fact or what was it in fact let me
try to historicize it historically it
was the replacement of one thology by
another right teos just means goal a
thology is a view of time which says
that it's all moving towards one goal
right so in 1989 to 1991 what tended to
happen among very smart people in this
in this part of the world was that they
said okay the story of Comm ism is not
true there's not an inevitable socialist
Revolution there's not an inevitable
communist Utopia therefore and this is
where this is the big mistake right you
you see it coming therefore another
story is true right and that other story
is the one about liberal democracy Now
admittedly The Advocates of liberal
democracy were neither as well-dressed
flashy or prone to die young as The
Advocates of Communism right and so they
kind of slipped in under the radar of
theoretical critique a little bit right
um but nevertheless this is also a
teeology the mistake is to say one
thology is wrong therefore another
thology is correct right that's that's
the fundamental mistake now the and so
what what follows why is this not
historical thinking right it's not
historical thinking because in this way
of seeing the world since you know
what's going to happen in the future
roughly I mean you don't know exactly
when or how but you know roughly we're
all you know the Arc of History there is
no Arc of History right there's no Arc
of history no Arc if you think you sorry
there is no there isn't right he was
wrong um it doesn't Bend either because
it's not an arc and you know and Justice
is up to you right so so the mistake is
if you think you know where history is
going then you don't have to know
anything about the past right or the the
few things that you know about the past
you can just work into the story of how
it has to end up in that particular
future right so actually you don't need
history right you can have knowing nods
about certain things in the past but you
don't really need history because you
don't need imagination you don't need
possibility because you already have a
certain conviction about where things
are going now what are the what are the
reactions to this or what are the what
are the syndromes associating with this
and I'm going to list some things which
I imagine you have experienced in your
own lives right and I will try to avoid
like embarrassing pop culture references
which date me while I do this but I
can't guarantee that I will
succeed paranoia right paranoia because
if there's only one way that things can
go in the future then there's a certain
tendency to say aha there's a master
plan there's a conspiracy right we have
to get out from under it okay first
embarrassing pop cultural reference this
is the Matrix view of History right the
M you go you you go to work there's a
cubicle you're dressed up more or less
like I'm dressed up right but then it
turns out there's a secret reality
underneath it that's a reaction to this
way of seeing the world like if there's
only one story you think oh wait there
should be a counter story right it
should ideally it should involve
carrying Moss leather special effects
really slow bullets okay I promise that
will be the last embarrassing pop
culture no I don't actually promise that
second um second reaction political
boredom okay the Germans have a good
word for this because they have a good
word for everything because they have an
amazing language Al alternative loik
kite right the absence of Alternatives
this is a name for this this is a name
for the politics of inevitability a name
for a syndrome the syndrome of boredom
if you accept that there are no
Alternatives right the politics of no
alter if you accept that there are no
Alternatives politics becomes
unbelievably boring because what happens
is in the two-party system one party
becomes the party of the status quo that
has to be and then the other party
becomes the party of um fancy crazy
rebellious system destroying ideas right
which aren't particularly articulate
they don't have to be be right so that's
the story of the United States right
it's also the story to a great deal of
of politics in Continental Europe
although there it's often two Centrist
parties are the ones who say no
alternative the status quo and then you
have a populist right-wing party which
says system destroying you know freeth
thinking all kinds of stuff right so
politics becomes very boring if you know
where things are going a word that
people have used a lot for this right in
English is
neoliberalism okay neoliberalism it's
bad yeah okay the problem with using
neoliberalism is that it Embraces
everything right it's a it's a word of
critique which actually fails completely
to critique because it means everything
right when people say neoliberalism they
basically mean they mean the lack of
Alternatives but they mean they don't
like the lack of Alternatives but
they're not usually providing an
alternative usually the word
neoliberalism is meant as a kind of
gesture of helplessness right as soon as
you say neoliberalism all the air goes
out of the room because you're just kind
of admitting there's no alternative to
it right that's just it it Embraces it
Embraces everything which leads to other
reactions like tell me you know just nod
please humor me nod discursiveness right
now you're already naughty I haven't
even said anything um just she also sits
in the front row in class
right she's totally reliable laughs at
all the jokes
um
um uh I don't know her Nam so there are
no grading issues here right um so um
okay so um
discursiveness if you can't talk about
the what right if you already know what
the what is the what can't change then
you only only talk about the how right
you describe you skate along the surface
you SK you skim along you know you
describe these superficial things um and
and the extreme of discursiveness comes
that thing called irony right irony
knowing irony right the wink and the nod
the critique which is not a critique
because again it doesn't actually
provide an alternative irony refers that
broad set of things which we all think
we know we knot our heads about it but
what are those things exactly right what
happens in irony is just the
reinforcement of the status quo
disruption a word which I hope never
ever to hear again but will because
Steve Bannon is is the Pol he uses that
word a lot disruption right what's the
idea of disruption disruption means
we're going to come along and disrupt
right what's the premise of disrupting
the premise is there's a system which
will automatically rebound no matter how
obnoxious we are how young we are how
anti- systemic we are we can disrupt and
that will be cool but the Assumption of
this is that there's a system which will
bounce back right but what if there
isn't what if there isn't a system which
will bounce back what if the notion of
disruption disruption is entirely empty
right then then where are we well
basically we are where we are now where
we have a disruptor in Chief right in in
in the White House okay who is going to
who brings things back after disruption
who is going to bring things back after
this particular disruption right I'm
looking at you and I'm nodding because
it's going to be you or nobody the big
problem nervous laughter the big
problem the big problem with with the
politics of inevitability is that it's
very vulnerable to shocks because if
anything happens of significance then
the scheme seems not to work people's
knees shake their voices shake they
don't know how to interpret something
like September 11th 2001 right because
it doesn't fit into a story like this
and since it doesn't fit into a story
and because you've taught yourself that
the actual past doesn't matter then when
there's a shock like this you simply say
everything is new right and everything
is new is just a baby step away from
everything is permitted so this already
happened to us once in 2001 I'm going to
suggest it's very likely to happen to us
again I'll get to that I'll get to that
later on but the the fundamental problem
of this the politics inevitability is
that it it itself seems inevitable until
it collapses right and it can right and
it will and it just has it just has
right that's that's over so the question
is what comes next there's another way
of thinking about time another
ahistorical another antihistorical way
of thinking about time and you know to
give away the game at the outset the
risk is for you for me for all of us
America the West the world the risk is
that we we shift from a politics of
inevitability Right Where where time
moves forward in a straight line to a
politics of Eternity right where you you
seem to have you again this seems to be
historical but but it's not what's the
politics of Eternity um the politics of
Eternity pant mes history by referring
to the past but by never quite putting
anything in order never quite explaining
anything it works in Concepts like
memory right memory in the 21st century
being a name for something which no one
actually remembers personally right um
commemoration Works under that name as
as well um uh it works by in scaning
certain things that happened in the past
in a kind of insecure chronology where
basically kind of everything happen at
the same time you know in the last
thousand years or 200 years or 100 years
however old your country happens to be
you think it is everything roughly
happens at the same time its key emotion
is Nostalgia but it's Nostalgia for
things that never happened right this is
the beautiful bait and switch of the
politics of Eternity you are meant to be
nostalgic all the time but none of the
things you're nostalgic for ever
actually took place and so you're drawn
in again and again and again into the
abyss so specifically right if Russia
builds a monument to uh Prince Vladimir
in Moscow right where he never lived
where he never could have lived because
the city didn't exist at the time when
he was alive right um not to mention
like all the personal flaws of king of
Prince Vladimir I'm just going to leave
those completely aside for like an extra
credit question on the exam but when you
do make a move when you make a move like
that right or if you're
Poland or France for that matter or
Britain even and you imagine an an
interwar period a 1920s or 1930s when
there was a nation state okay France and
Britain have never been nation states
which is why the Nostalgia of brexit is
a Nostalgia for nothing France has never
been a nation state it was an Empire and
then it folded into a European
integration project it has never been a
nation state when the
talks about a France before interaction
with the world there never was such a
place you're being asked to be nostalgic
for a world that never was right you
think you're taking a cautious step back
and in fact you're throwing yourself
basically into a kind into a kind of
black ho into kind of black hole the way
that all events in the past are gathered
up in the politics of fraternity is in
regularities in patterns and the
simplest pattern it usually really is
this is the pattern of uh aggression
from the outside penetration from the
outside of a of a virtuous nation which
is always in the right right in Eastern
Europe This is romanticism right which
which which which lives on which which
lives on and so the past is all just
it's Cycles right it's Cycles the same
things happen over and over again with
different guises right we're always
attacked from the West we're always
attacked or from the East maybe it's
from we're always attacked from the East
right um there are always too many
immigrants whatever it might be it's
it's a pattern it's a cycle it's a
regularity and because it's a pattern or
cycle or regularity there's no need to
try to interpret or explain or to see
one event is really any different from
any other and above all and this is
important no one actually has any
responsibility it's very hard to think
about politics in this kind of world
it's very hard to think about leadership
and precisely in this kind of world the
notion of a leader with a capital l
right um a du a a leader with a capital
l who comes from outside of history and
somehow saves redeems rescues the nation
or the folk right from from all of this
threat from outside it's in this it's in
the politics of Eternity where this
notion of a political savior makes makes
sense now once you slip into this way of
thinking about time again it's like the
politics of notability you don't really
need to know anything about the past not
really because you it will be explained
to you who the enemies always are and
how there's regularly a threat and your
experience of time will be of constant
threat of emergency right of the
exception as the rule the exception
becomes the rule the sense of threat the
building that blows up right the
terrorist attack this is always
happening or if it isn't always
happening it's always about to happen
right it's always about to happen and in
such a world how can you think about the
future future how dare you think about
the future when we are under so much
pressure right now when the enemy is
always at the gate how can you imagine
reforming the state when the state is
there to protect us right how can you
even think of that it's disloyal of you
to imagine a future right this is the
way the politics of Eternity works
there's a wide bandwidth of how this
works right but at the end of this
bandwidth is something called fascism
now these are two other ways of of
thinking about time that are not
historical and the reason why it seems
to me so important to be talking about
them now is that we could be shifting
from one of them to the other I haven't
been particularly happy in the politics
of inevitability right um I don't think
that many of you are going to be very
happy in the politics of Eternity and
the question is how you stop from
slipping from one to the other because
it's very easy afraid to go straight
from one to the other it's very easy to
go from The View that things are always
going to turn out in the end somehow to
the view that things are never going to
turn out in the end somehow it's very
easy to go from the view of I should
cooperate with my elders and authorities
because they've told me the truth about
how things are always going to get
better to I should cooperate with my
elders and the authorities because I
don't have any other idea of what I
should do with my life right things are
patterns of mind and behavior which are
very similar from inevitability can slip
into eternity right and this is this is
my this is my concern about you about
all of us but in particular about you so
um any historical thought that you have
any effort that you make to think
historically any engagement with history
is itself um a sort of resistance to
this in so far as you're thinking
historically you are inoculating
yourself against both of these time
Scapes whether you realize it or not
you're you're you're creating a little
moment you're you're creating time
you're producing you're producing time
you're producing imagination you're
producing relativism you're producing
thought okay so that's the introduction
now what I want to do with the rest is
give you a few examples of how the 20th
century might be relevant why is the
introduction so important because I
don't want to just tell you that here
are some lessons from yes there are
lessons from the 20th century and the
things the events I'm going to talk talk
about are are events in which thousands
tens of thousands hundreds of thousands
sometimes millions of people died right
it's not that they're insignificant
events but I don't just want to list
them as lessons I want you to see that
the stakes of of taking on history at
all are very high you don't have to
agree with all of the lessons right and
certainly there are other lessons you
could draw from other places I happen to
know about Central and Eastern Europe so
that's what I'm going to talk about now
you can draw lessons from other places
but as soon as you're thinking
historically you're already doing a lot
for yourself if you're thinking about
history right you can draw lessons from
other things right you can you know you
from from from from Blight right or from
Gilmore um you can you can draw you can
draw lessons about the novelty of
American History right the notion for
example that America is an old democracy
it's not it's not it's an old state but
it's only been a democracy in a in the
sense that we understand it for about as
long as I've been alive
which don't hurt my feelings right it's
not that long it's not that long and if
you do American history or especially
African-American history you can get
purchase on this and you can and and you
and you can and you can see it right
civil rights environmental legislation
let alone you know partnership rights
and marriage these are all things that a
70-year-old can remember in America
without right these things are all very
new in that sense in in in in in flux um
but what I what I want to try to do is
contemplate the past using some examples
that I know something about right that's
now the longest I've ever spoke about
American history in public right ever um
except except in department meetings
right
um um and so and I want to do this in
three ways I'm going to go over the 20th
century in in in a fairly Hasty way and
I'm going to break the 20th century into
three parts which are going to do three
things I hope the first part is to
familiarize right the idea being that
things that are happening now although
they're not just like things that
happened 100 years ago they're close
enough that you can you know get some
purchase that you can see some
similarities and you can feel like
you're not entirely um at lost or or
alone the the second part will be about
recognition this will be mostly about
the 30s and 40s and the atrocities of
the 30s and 40s the things that one has
to watch out for and the third part will
be mostly about the 60s 70s and 80s
about communism in Eastern Europe and
will have to do with tactics of
resistance so the third part is
recommendations okay
familiarization
familiarization first point um
globalizations they come they come and
they go they come and they go right they
come and they go like we we have this
idea that our globalization is special
the I mean I look at our globalization I
think the thing which is hard about our
globalization is that everybody has a
stupid screen in front of their face the
entire time which makes it really hard
to paint their portrait right like have
you noticed how hard it is to make
somebody look happy holding a smartphone
right or even look human right have you
noticed how hard advertisers have to
struggle to make someone look happy
right like this is like the big
advertising marketing struggle of art
anyway okay second embarrassing pop
cultural reference somebody's going to
keep count um but the our Global the
point is our globalization is not new
there's nothing particularly great great
about our globalization the one this is
that people count differently I think
this is the second one other historians
would say there have been others but the
globalization that started in the
1870s was very similar to ours World
Trade vast economic growth export driven
growth um multilingualism fantastically
comparative literature much better than
our own fantastically comparative poetry
much better than our own huge um huge
increases in the pace of technological
change including some really interesting
Technologies some of which are arguably
superior to the ones we're we're using
now a sense a self-conscious sense that
globalization was happening the same
kinds of predictions about what
globalization would mean that is the
spread of liberalism um Peace and later
democracy basically the same consensus
in in the late 19th century as we had in
the late 20th and early 21st century
that's already happened once okay and it
failed that doesn't mean it has to fail
again it just just means that it was
there once and we don't have to feel if
if our globalization seems to be under
threat which it is we don't have to feel
like okay we're in this completely new
place there are no there are no points
of guidance so similarly confidence in
globalization or what I'm going to call
liberalism not in the American sense but
like I mean liberalism in the sense that
there are rules that governed things
very basic sense of liberalism um
confidence in liberalism also comes and
goes okay so the fact that people were
very confident in the '90s and in the
what do we call them the as what do we
call the the zeros the as okay the fact
that people were very uh confident for a
while and then they're not confident at
all now that's also not new right the
same thing happens in the first
globalization people are quite confident
about liberalism until right around 1900
and then we have you know the beauty of
psychoanalysis expressionism Balkan Wars
first world war you know Great
Depression and it just gets worse after
after after that right so Li liberal
confidence can come and go this doesn't
mean that it h that it's doomed right so
if you see that everyone is shaky about
the rules that govern things yeah they
could all go away that's possible it's
happened but it this isn't something new
right this is not something
unprecedented there's no reason why you
have to lose your confidence because
there have been reactions um next next
Point
familiarization um to to to to do away
with ideas of rule R around the world
you always or pretty much always appeal
to Eternity so this this thing that I'm
talking about like my my obsession with
losing the sense of time moving forward
and that being replaced suddenly with a
sense that time is flat the re one of
the reasons why I'm so preoccupied with
that is that that's how it happened the
last time right there's a light version
of this which begins in Vienna 1900
where you have the men who are not
really rich pretending to be rich and
appealing to the working class providing
alternatives to globalization which
involve protectionism right um and an
odd mix of the old and the new which of
the up and the down right as it was
famously put by Robert muel and then by
Carl Shori um which works politically
that's the soft version the harder
versions are fascism with its obsession
with Rome national socialism with with
obsession with a Reich a Thousand-Year
Reich and above all with its notion that
there is no history only
biological
regularities right only only races is
inferior Superior friendly friendly and
and and and enemy um these are the ways
that reactions these are the reactions
that we know come when liberalism
shutters we know that that's important
final familiarization right I'm trying
I'm trying to make the present like you
see how this works you can make the
present less surprising right not that
the present is particularly attractive
but you can make it less surprising by
looking at very similar events on a
large scale right the fourth one
inequality matters a lot so I talk about
I've talked about communism I'm talk
about fascism I'm going to talk about
them some more when we say when we say
fascists we usually mean something like
evil irrational mad people right when we
say Communists we mean um what do we
mean like evil irrational mad
intellectuals I think is what is usually
meant at least in this particular
discursive space and when we make that
move which pretty much every American
always makes at least in mass media of
dismissing them for being mad or wearing
spectacles or both um when we make that
move what we're doing is we're
forgetting why those things were
attractive right and one of the reasons
why they were attractive was that the
first globalization really did bring
massive inequality and perceived local
inequality right inequality is global
but it also it functions on fractal
level and how you feel compared to the
people who are right around you also
matters a great deal right so fascism
promises that we're going to protect you
from the global economy we're going to
make a national economy we're going to
make it bigger by taking more land right
communism promises we're going to
protect you from it from inequality
we're going to look at the poorest the
most miserable we're going to raise them
up by accelerating development right
these are reactions to inequality I'm
not saying that means that they were
they were good things I'm just saying
that inequality mattered a huge amount
in the first globalization and it
matters an awful lot in ours as well um
it it cannot be discarded the way that
we'd like to discard it okay that's Rec
that's that's some that's
familiarization
recognition recognition is about what
are some of the things that can go wrong
and you might be saying well some things
have already gone wrong yeah some things
have already gone wrong and some things
went wrong well before the obvious
things that went wrong but you know as
as as my friend and colleague Ellie
Ellie staron was saying to me like on
the street the other day um you know the
lesson of East European history is that
you can't say it's not going to get
worse because at every point right in
East European history people have been
saying that it's not it can't get worse
right and then and then it and then it
and then it does or then it did okay so
what can you recognize first um the
magic of the one party state right what
why are one party States so magical
what's their special force because one
party state is a way of moving from a
normal political system with a
constitution and elections and so on to
one that's less normal and it can be
done gradually right so the Nazi
takeover of power doesn't just happen
overnight with elections although
elections matter it happens gradually as
one party crowds out other parties as
other parties are made illegal as people
get used to a simulacrum of the previous
institutions with in fact only one party
that's allowed to function second thing
to look out for to recognize the
demonopolization of violence that fancy
so MOX vber had this idea that the state
will always aspire to a monopoly on
legitimate violence right so the
policeman should be always be working
for the state right the Army should be
part of the state something to watch out
for is when the state Council supports
endorse funds trains groups that are
armed are violent that are not really
part of the state that are that are not
they may wear uniforms right they may
March in interesting formations right
they may have ranks and salutes but
they're not part of the state but they
bear arms right I'm talking about the
SAA and and and the SS in case you don't
in case you haven't follow me those are
those are those are demonopolization
they then change the state this is the
second thing to be to watch out for the
third thing to watch out for and if I
like if I had to choose one of these
things for like the bumper sticker I
don't drive very much so I'm not a
bumper sticker um for like the sign that
you taped to my back okay if I had to
choose one thing for that it would be
Reich talk fire okay it would be the
politics of Emergency the exception
becoming the rule you ask you ask who
set the Reich you know what I'm talking
the Reich stock fire right right a month
after Hitler comes to power the somebody
sets the German Parliament on fire this
leads to many important things the
suspension of other political parties
putting lots of people in concentration
camps and the Declaration of a state of
emergency which then becomes normal
because it's never it's it's never
lifted right that's that's the reog fire
right um the the what the reog fire is
important here for us as a landmark is
that that's the kind of thing which does
away with the way you're thinking about
time and politics and freedom now right
a Reich fire is the kind of thing which
creates a sense of permanent emergency
because how you know how could they have
done this to us it it it creates a new
kind of legitimacy for authorities maybe
they came to Power by elections but it's
their reaction to this Grand emergency
which gives them a new kind of
legitimacy right um and uh and and and
and Above All Above All okay who set The
re's Talk
fire it doesn't matter who set the right
talk fire right there was actually
debate about this still going on but it
doesn't matter who set the reog fire
right when the reog fire comes again we
may not know who said it and it's not
going to matter too much right what's
going to matter is how people react to
that immediate sense of oh nothing like
this has ever happened before right
which is what everyone always says even
though this happens with numbing
regularity right when it happens again
people are going to say this has never
happened before hence state of ception
hence emergency right and the question
is how do you react to that if you react
to it historically you think aha 1933
there are plenty of other examples but
you think 1933 there there's there's
room for maneuver here there possible
for possibilities for manipulation we
don't have to go straight into um
straight into into into flat time right
into into eternity um uh
relatedly watch out for the words
terrorism and exceptional especially
extremism I mean I'm aware that there is
such a thing as terrorism right but I'm
also aware that every authoritarian
regime in the history of modern politics
talks about terrorism all the time and
extremism what is that exactly right
we've got so like we've gotten used to
saying terrorism extremism or at least
hearing it I hope you're not saying it
terrorism extremist terrorists and
extremist what is there an actual
extremist
Doctrine right um I mean I consider
myself an extremist when it comes to the
defense of things that I think are truly
important and I hope other people would
consider that I mean I don't think like
oh US Constitution you know it's about
the same you know Skittles you know it's
not it's not all the same to me right so
in that sense because it's not all the
same to me I am an extremist and I hope
that all of you are as well you don't
have to have the same values I hope that
you have some okay um I hope there's
something that you feel extremely about
and if you if you there is then you're
an extremist right and we're all
extremists and you know know extremism
in the defense of Liberty is no Vice
right um so watch out for that because
extremism ends up just meaning what's
not in the mainstream where the
mainstream is the thing which the
leaders have just defined as being the
mainstream a day ago or moment ago or in
the same sentence
perhaps
recognition the personification of
globalization okay so globalization is
real it's difficult it's problematic we
all have to deal with it what leaders do
what in particular Adolf Hitler did was
to personify it it's not a set of
impersonal forces it's not a challenge
it's not a difficulty it's the
Jews right and that's not just Theory
it's also practice you you you say that
a Jew is not a person not your neighbor
not a citizen of Germany but a member of
velt udum of world jury right you
literally globalize that person and you
you put all the negative aspects of
globalization inside that person and
that's a form of politics I because that
that extrudes the person from the
apartment building the local community
the school eventually the country and
all the people who are not globalized in
this way pitch in by taking the property
taking the place in school taking
whatever it is and they get involved in
in in that way right um okay fifth thing
um the suspended State watch out for
this watch out for people who say the
state's not important that all we have
to do is disrupt the state it would be
cool to destroy the state and see what
happens next plenty of guilty parties a
long list of American politicians and um
you know on both the left and the right
who have ideas like this one of them is
now you know the chief policy adviser in
the white house um to have a great
Terror in the Soviet Union you have to
suspend even in the Soviet Union you
have to defend the state you have to
sorry you have to suspend the state you
have to declare a state of emergency
even in Nazi German gery to carry out a
holocaust they don't do it in their own
country they can't it's too much of a
rule of law state Nazi Germany is too
much of a rule of law state despite
everything they do it in places where
they have invaded and destroyed the
state and declared the state doesn't
exist so watch out for people who tell
you that the state is just kind of an
artifact right I mean the state like all
the other things I'm talking about has
its problems but you can't have the rule
of law without it um just try right just
try that's what the 1930s were people
who lost the rule of law because they
lost the state okay so um this brings me
to the the last set of things I wanted I
wanted to talk to you about which is
recommendations now if I were a West
this is the move which I make when I
become a West europeanist if I were a
West
europeanist I would say there were two
big lessons of the second World War two
big lessons of the 20th century um the
first would be that the you can repair
this thing I'm calling liberalism a
liberal order
by way of uh by way of Economic Policy
right you can have monetarism you can
have you can have you can you can spend
right you can deficit spend you can make
sure that you have free trade regionally
like these are practical lessons and
they're and and they're true and and and
and they're and and they're really
important um you a second lesson of the
second world war like West Europeans
would say would be and it's also true
would be um yeah nation states have
problems therefore they should work
together okay I'll just make leave it at
that level of banality um Poland might
not be functional Portugal might not be
functional but all of them together in a
free trade zone in in in a single
economy right that happens to be the
largest economy in the history of the
world with a much higher standard of
living than the United States it's a
bigger economy than China's still right
I realize you don't like turn open your
newspaper and you get the headline
European Union great right you don't get
that headline which is it's funny right
because you know it's pretty great it's
a bigger economy than ours better
transparency lower rates of corruption
higher reported happiness
right and all we get is when things blow
up but anyway I'll just leave that as
aide um so those would be the West
European lessons and I think they're
true I don't want to disregard them but
what I want to concentrate on is the way
that East Europeans who had a long
stretch under communism
rethought liberal and democratic theory
and the things which which they added
which are which are useful and
interesting um one of them is I've
already mentioned is Extreme care
with the language right uh East
Europeans faced with Communism realized
that language turning individuals into
members of groups turning groups into
inevitable historical Trends drawing
policy conclusions on the basis of that
right that the first step the use of
language is
extremely important and therefore when
they opposed the first step that they
made when they opposed was to think try
to think of a different kind of set of
words words it seems very simple but try
to use different different words and um
you know this is this is Orwell's
preoccupation um and of course in order
to be able to do this you have to read
books because if you just W I mean I'm
sorry to sound like even older than I am
but if you just watch television or if
you just follow your own goddamn
Facebook feed you get the same words
over and over and over again and they
start to speak through you right they
start to speak through you which you can
say Slavic languages right but you can't
say English they start to speak through
you rather than you choosing the words
you use yourself and how are you going
to have those words you're going to read
um you know you're going to read Orwell
above all I think on this particular on
this particular issue second thing
concern with factuality right so when
you're faced with um when you're faced
with the politics of inevitability or
the politics of of Eternity what's
what's what's a move that you make a
move that you make is that you try to
rescue the individual fact from the big
story right whether it's a story of
progress or whether it's a story of
Eternal victimhood right you try to
rescue the individual fact you try to
make the individual facts your own at
this point in neverly arises the
question what is truth right and I go
back to my original Matrix reference
what what is what is truth which I'm not
I'm not going to solve for you guys here
today but I'm going to say the following
I mean it earnestly if what is truth
that question if that's you know that
can be a pose and that can be an excuse
for doing nothing or it can be a search
and I earnestly recommend that it be the
latter that it be that it be a search as
it was for the East European dissidents
of the
1970s next um next next recommendation
would be watching out for conformism
okay this one is hard I mean I don't
mean to hit home too hard here so I
won't but I mean you guys know you're
guilty right so I mean yeah right no you
don't think because you're dress
differently and stuff okay I'll give it
to you um uh yeah right wake up if
you're awake so the
conformism watch out for conformism and
and how do you know when you're being a
conformist when you don't feel awkward
all the time because the people who
Stand Out always feel awkward freedom
feels awkward and the mo the moments
where freedom is actually at stake by
which I mean now for you guys are the
moments when people have to feel awkward
now what what's conformism okay it
sounds bad everything I put an ism on is
going to sound bad I'm I'm making the
mistake I I I you know what's conformism
who's a conformist who would say I'm a
conform nobody it's not an ideology okay
what's conformism self-censorship is
conformism you know when you don't write
down the things or say the things you
might otherwise say and self-censorship
is a is is a species of a larger problem
which is called anticipatory
obedience when you obey in advance when
you use your precious
creativity um and your hardfought social
skills to think so it's normal right to
be creative and think of what should I
do but to be creative about what
somebody else is going to want for you
from you right it's a subtle move but
it's profoundly important it's normal to
use your social skills to think oh what
does the other person want I should
start with them not with me that's great
right but it's it's it's a different
thing subtly profoundly different to say
okay what does power one I'm going to
meet power halfway I'm going to do an
advance when you harness your own
creativ like those are things which
could be serving your own individual
let's say freedom when those things are
harnessed for obedience in advance you
are doing the work of power for it right
and that is about 90% of how
authoritarianism works right there so
when I say conformism it isn't just like
you're all going to like you know it's
not like a it's I don't mean like in a
commercial where like you just March
down you I mean conformism in that you
use your individual gifts right of which
you were you know fortunate to have so
many you use your individual gifts to
think about how you can move yourself
your future towards what power wants
this is what usually happens it ought
not to happen uh couple more Civil
Society right Civil Society recognize
that all the modern authoritarianism
including the ones that are working
right now are allergic on this question
of civil society that is of groups that
are neither individuals nor the
government the easiest way to rule is it
for to be the government and a bunch of
adoms right Adams individual moral
people who are morally and
psychologically isolated that's an easy
ruling situation if you have civil
society that is if you have people who
are doing things together which are not
they don't have to be political things
right they can be anything really but
people doing things together that are
neither for nor against the government
that creates connections it creates
professional ethics it works against
atomization right it creates confidence
it may create something which is
extremely important which is trust if
nobody trusts anybody authoritarianism
is really
easy if if some groups trust other
groups authoritarianism becomes much
harder because if nobody trusts anybody
right then you know then all there's
left is power if nobody trusts anybody
resistance if necessary becomes totally
impossible because you cannot you cannot
resist all by yourself you have to you
have to be able to trust someone you
have to have that particular attitude
and Civil Society also creates Authority
like in the sense of journalistic
authority right in the sense of trusting
not just individuals but maybe some
institutions right that there there
there are collectivities out there that
aren't the state but that you might
trust for example for for information
okay um final okay couple okay I'll just
give you one more the way that communism
ends had to do with with people trusting
one another not just in individual civil
societies but with people sharing
Reflections across countries in the
United States we are not alone now right
the things that have happened to us in
the last year I mean for me it's like a
nightmare because basically like
everything that happens in Ukraine now
happens in America but just with less
style right and and everyone is just is
like much slower to react to it which
makes me crazy right you know my
Ukrainian friends are constantly like
ukra like a Ukrainian journalist shows
up and just like sniffs the air in Ohio
and says yeah he's gonna take the state
right and she's
right and she's right right you know and
and this is the way this is what's
happened in the world a little bit is
that I mean I'm not just talking about
the so-called West but things that
happened in Russia and Ukraine you know
for a while things that happened here
then happened there okay but now things
that happen there happen here basically
if you have to generalize but the point
is that it's good to have Hungarian
friends um not just for the cooking it's
good to have Hungarian friends because
they can tell you what it looks like
when a rule of law state is step by step
demolished without actually breaking the
law or coming close to not breaking the
law right it's good to have Russian
friends because they can tell you what
really slick effective state sponsored
high production value television
propaganda looks like feels like how it
how it works and so on and so on and so
on right we're not actually alone in in
in this we've just joined a much larger
a much larger Trend now the final thing
I want to say about examples um the
notion of a failed transition okay so
back in 1989 when we were entering into
this m this this moment of politics of
inevitability which is now over which is
now over um when we entering into this
moment people talked about transitions
which is always a telogical concept
right because a transition assumes that
you know what's at the end of something
there's a process but you also know
what's going to happen right and so if
there's a transition the transition was
to democracy or capitalism right if
there's a transition then there are only
two possibilities there's a successful
transition there's a failed transition
if you're thinking that way you look at
a place like Ukraine or a place like
Russia and you say oh failed transition
it's therefore irrelevant right um it's
therefore as President Obama very
unfortunately in my view said it's
therefore just a a regional power right
you know and this is the whole way that
we thought about Eastern Europe
unfortunately in the Obama
Administration that well there are
general rules and the general rules have
to do with people being enlightened and
rational and one economic growth and so
in the long run in the long run there
shouldn't be Wars in in Europe or
Invasion that shouldn't be happening
right so let's bracket it because
eventually history will come to the
rescue no no no no no it never comes to
the rescue right um Russia and Ukraine
and other places Hungary Poland if you
want these are not failed transitions
these are these are these are
interesting political systems run by
very intelligent people who are playing
by different rules many of whom think
that their rules have to spread Westward
for them to maintain power at home it's
not that they've like fallen off the
mainstream right and therefore you can
ignore them they're doing something
different and the thing that they are
doing is catching on here too right so
the the the the point of all this is is
to say that like for good for good and
for ill um we are we are all in this
together oh Ukraine okay there's there's
an interesting Ukrainian model which I
just want to share with you so let's say
that you're a kind of like makeb believe
oligarch not me I'm always happy when
it's not me um the
uh let's let's say that you're like a a
baby oligarch right they're like you're
a makeb believe oligarch you want people
to think you're ol you're not really an
oligarch but it's kind of like your
thing to be an oligarch right like
that's your thing like gold flashiness
like lots of you know lots of sort of
80s era bling um you know like like your
restaurants have sliders you know like
that kind of thing um let's say you're
that right um and like you really want
your kids to be really rich you know
like that's C if you have another thing
it's that you want your kids and then
let's say you know you succeed in
breaking down um what there is of the
rule of law you succeeded in becoming
the biggest oligarch in the country
right it's not that you love Russia
particularly but Russia will help you
out in this particular direction it's
not that even you don't like democracy
it's just that democracy can sometimes
get in the way of this project of making
your son unbelievably wealthy right
that's Ukraine under yanukovich more or
less I mean that that more or less just
happened one doesn't have to I'm trying
to say one doesn't have to reach all the
way back to the 30s and 40s and one
doesn't have to have just the most dire
examples to see things which might be
happening oh let's say your political
adviser is Paul man for it right I mean
it just goes on these resemblances just
go on and on and on we've become very
Ukrainian without knowing you know
without knowing what that means except
you know all of you of course know what
it means well unfortunately you only
know what it means up to about 1912 at
this point right so I need you in the
second semester of the class okay so
fine okay the end the end what does this
what does this mean for you okay you you
know you know what my basic point is my
basic point is that where you have been
where you have spent your lives up to
now and you can like you can Riot later
but where you have no in fact I want you
to Riot later right that's the point
like I'm giving you permission to Riot
later Riot later not while the camera's
on but later um the um no because if you
do it when the camera's on then
everybody on the YouTube video will just
like they'll just like go down to the
riot part they'll be like the emails
Riot is at 43 minutes 22
seconds right and then no one will
listen to my lecture so don't write so
later later okay so where where you you
know my main point that the politics of
inevitability is where you've been it's
how we've how we raised you
unfortunately right it's completely
unbelievable now and I hope you
understand but that's sort of been the
mistake I think the previous generation
has made with yours and it's a very
powerful mistake and it's a it's it's a
very was a very risky Gambit and now it
hasn't worked the politics of Eternity
is where you might be going right it's
where you might be going it's fairly
easy it's fairly easy to get there and
the question then becomes how we think
about what this is right now right is it
a turning point like the notion of a
turning point is very passive it's
geometrical you know mathematical you
know are we really are we really in
Geometry you know is is all this going
to is like the you know the the the
suffocated time of inevitability is it
going to become the starve time of of
Eternity or can you build out a moment
right from this Turning Point can you
build out a moment for yourselves can
you produce time like can you see time
can you produce time can you make this
thing which is the now become a kind of
moment right which is special like all
moments are different like all moments
are but also in some sense not different
also understandable in reference to
things that you know about or could know
about from from the past now this this
business of creating time I don't mean
it metaphorically I mean time is a
precondition to political action it's a
precondition to Freedom what
inevitability and Eternity do in
different ways in the different degrees
they take away they take away time now
and you also know that I think that some
of the things that go on some of the
ways that the culture functions are
going to make it some of the things that
you do okay let me give you agency make
it or make it relatively easy to slide
from inevitability to Eternity right
this whole notion of disruption which I
mentioned earlier right that's very sexy
when you think that everything's
inevitable and like if you can disrupt
as much as you want it's still going to
bounce back it isn't going to bounce
back it's over right it's not going to
there's nothing to bounce back there's
nothing to bounce back um post po post
catastrophism right I mean all of the
films that you know you may not consume
but which I I I'm aware of and maybe I
sometimes watch like all of the films
where there is no State and there is
there is no State there are no rules
everyone's just fighting for
resources that's a problem mentally
right because the you jump you jump all
the the games right which I just know
you don't play late at night on huge
screens in basement I know you don't
play these games but so let me describe
them to you they're post-catastrophic
right whether there's a catastrophe or
not is the important question like what
post catastrophism looks like that's a
leap ahead right but the thing to think
about is is how to stop the catastrophe
from actually happening right to take to
take a certain amount of of
responsibility because that's what
history I think means a certain amount
of responsibility not all of it you know
God forbid but a certain amount of
responsibility if you see that there are
structures but those structures can be
moved a a little bit then you have a
certain like the moment you realize that
then you have a certain amount of
responsibility not a lot but everyone
but everyone has everyone has a little
so this is what you know this is what
um this is why you know I think of you I
really do right like I'm not like when
when I lecture you're not all in my
class and that's cool I like that so
forgive me the references as you but
when you come to class on on Tuesday or
whenever it is I'm not going to be this
nice so just like soak it up right now I
think like you have a chance to be a
historical generation right you have a
chance to be a historical generation you
can make this time historical time you
have a CH it's I mean it in two senses
right like you could be important but
also you could be the generation which
gets people thinking historically again
right in the sense of of generating
possibility of of of generating you know
of generating connections now that's the
that's that's the nice part here comes
the here comes the not nice part I think
you will be you will be I mean you know
who be all prophetic I could be totally
wrong but you will be remembered I think
right as as a as a historical generation
or not at all or not at all because if
we slide into eternity in a soft version
or a hard version then you just don't
matter right then you just don't matter
you're not even a bump in the road right
because it's not even a road it's just
flat asphalt and desert out to an empty
Horizon forever right so you I think you
will be a I think you can be I think you
can be I think you will be a historical
generation but if you don't generate
history history is not going to remember
you as as a generation right so you know
Millennial can be something that repeats
or it can be nothing at all I don't know
yet right you you guys are going to
you're going to you're going to tell me
okay um I'm going to end with I'm going
to end with Hamlet because I just read
it and it's on my list of things that
everyone should read right now it's
actually it's really wonderful in these
particular times but one of hamlets
early soliloquies he he ends with um the
time is out of joint uh o cursed spite
that ever I was born to set it right
that's where you are right that's where
you are the time is out of joint we're
not in inevitability anymore we're not
in eternity yet it's floating right you
could build out moments I don't know if
you will I don't know if we will but it
could happen things are out of joint
they're going to fall back into some
pattern or another soon but right now
they're they're out of joint now Hamlet
one thing you reason to read Hamlet is
that it goes very badly for Hamlet right
it goes terribly for Hamlet it goes
terribly for I'm not saying everything's
going to go well you know I mean as many
of you know I think things could go
extraordinarily badly right things go
very badly for Hamlet for the court for
his friends for for Denmark in the story
but in the beginning in the beginning is
where we are what he actually says is
time is out of Joy No cursed spite that
ever I was born to put it right and then
the last line he says nay
come let's go together right and you can
can and I hope you will that's it
thank
you so we'll be doing a question and
answer session uh there's microphones on
both sides of the room so if you have a
question just raise your hand and we'll
bring a
microphone uh hi so I I asked this
question with with all respect um I'd
like to think from an inspiring
historian to actual historian um all all
all historians are
aspiring at moments like this I mean um
historians members of The Academy U
speak in metaphors speak in timely
metaphors um I think you see it a lot
with um we in Centennial right now um
The Academy looks to South China Sea and
likes to make this kind of
um and I think a metaphor that's very
popular at this moment and one that you
yourself have engaged in is the metaphor
both a little bit tonight but also
recently it's like magazine and I'm
wondering um to what extent that how
long does that remain appropriate how
long does it remain constructive because
if we kind of play that metaphor out we
find ourselves somewhere between hit's
election in 1933 and are awaiting our
own fire which is in a sense saying
we're all kind
um or um the alternative is that um what
I feel is that um there's a certain
amount of optimism of kind of faith in
legal structures um of the country um
that uh at this point it seems too early
to to tell that they'll they will fail
us kind of result in this and so I'm
just wondering at a at a kind of
rhetorical level um where does that
language kind of ultimately take us and
what um kind of what do you see
kind going forward as we kind of watch
events on okay so let me start with 1914
2014 because that that's an example
that's an example of um uh that's a
little tiny example of of politics of
Eternity creeping in people don't even
notice so there's a war in Ukraine in
2014 but it's the Centennial of
1914 and so the metaphor that everyone
uses to use your word metaphor there
when people talk about Ukraine in 2014
like they're constantly thinking about
1914 and they can't help it because it's
being the Centennial right the memory
the commemoration all these things which
aren't actually history those things are
in everyone's mind right and so the the
the idiotic shamanistic accident that
one Wars a hundred years after another
has true histo has true
historical consequences right I'm
against that okay and I'm also against
I'm also against the notion that there's
an alternative which like our language
forces us into and way there I'm trying
to find I'm trying to demonstrate or I'm
trying to use language in a different
way when I talk about Hitler I'm neither
saying that it's inevitable that we have
Reich talk fire blah blah blah nor am I
saying our institutions are better than
the Germans therefore that's exactly
what I'm not doing I'm trying to do
something I'm trying to say in history
including the Nazi Germany which is just
its history it's history like other
history there are certain patterns there
are certain things that go together and
certain things that don't go together
right um and I I I'm not at all saying I
hope I was very clear about this that
we're in some kind of
deterministic path right the very notion
that we're in a deterministic path is
the thing that I'm trying to to fight
against I hope clearly what I'm trying
to say instead is that if we have a
sense of things that are a little bit
like and a little bit unlike we then
have a wider Horizon of possibility in
terms of what we think could happen in
the US right because I think more things
are possible here than people generally
realize but also a wider sense of
possibility in how we might react right
so we know it's like I'm saying reich's
hog fire I'm not saying that therefore
inevitably there will be a discussion
about it whether a Dutch Anarchist did
it you know no you know I'm not saying
anything inevitably I'm saying if there
was a similar event like so you know
Skip to 911 a lot of the ways that
reacted to 911 were you know politics of
emergency never happened before and so
on when we get the next 911 do we CH do
we choose to react the same way or do we
choose to react a different way talking
about the I don't when I talk about the
re talk fire for me it's not a metaphor
right for me it's a fire right um for
for me it's it's a set of events which I
feel like I more or less understand for
me it's a moment which I think that
other people could also invive as a
moment which is why you know for me
history is moments and the more moments
you have the better chance you have
right it's it's something it's something
like that so like I I can't engage at
the level you want me to because I'm
against the whole I'm against the whole
step back to this is discourse and I'm
against the whole step back to this is
metaphor I'm just against those things
now I don't honestly don't think we have
time for them right Nazi Germany is
blazingly relevant we can we can agree
we can talk about why or or why not but
what I won't do is say okay I'm going to
talk about the appropriateness of I'm
just not right I think we're past that
right I I I'll be calmer
now
thank you so
much and um I feel like you gave us this
long spectrum of what you know what
we've left behind because it proved
false and you're warning us against what
we're in danger of going
towards and you name the ends of the
spectrum and I'm trying to figure out
how to con convey this idea to others
without reciting the four pages of notes
in my laptop and I'm wondering what do
you call the middle and how do you
convey it in a more concise compelling
manner because I'm not saying me back
tremendously compelling that's cool but
if I've only got like two minutes or
three minutes and I'm not saying to tell
me the two- minute version or the three
minute version but what I'm guess I'm
trying to say is how do you name what
you've said because what you're saying
is create the history between those that
is neither of those but I don't really
know what I stand for and I actually
think it's veryable fact about the
election right we know what we are
against and often didn't know what we
were for so similar problem but we can
get into that later that was a side
point but I want to know what are you
calling the middle of the spectrum and
how do you convey that idea in a
compelling manner because everybody
wants to make history that idea like you
said that idea isn't new but there is
something between those dangerous ends
of the spectrum that I'm trying to
understand I don't know how to talk
about it yeah okay I mean you're there
that's that's that's that's tough so I
mean let me let me start a little bit
with one of your premises the election
like we all like what you describe as
part of the issue right there was a
certain lack of clarity about what
people were for especially on some of
the most fundamental issues and the way
that the Clinton campaign went for it
especially at the end with what we were
against right I mean when I when I when
I was when I was in the Midwest and
watching Those ads I they felt
differently to me than than than than
here you know the the you know we can't
trust them with the nuclear codes and
that kind of thing that a lot of that
turned out to be advertising for for
Trump in the end right so like just
knowing what you're against isn't the
same it's not it's not actually a
logical problem where if you know what
you're against therefore you know what
you're for and there was an issue there
and I think with the Democrats there is
an issue not I me I don't mean that in a
personal way um but I mean it's like
it's this problem of boredom that arises
from politics of inevitability because
with you know both Clinton and Obama
with all the appropriate qualifications
and with all their differences they're
representing a party which is the we're
the status quo we're going to stop the
Mad people from ging power party right
that's the Democrats in the US they're
like the know you know they're like
they're like the esped the 20s they're
the party which says like if you have to
vote for us because otherwise it's going
to be a disaster basically that always
loses it always loses I mean it might
win once or twice but it always loses in
the end because people do not
understandably do not think that that's
a sensible way of understanding the
future of their lives right so this is a
little bit of the problem now what this
thing is okay I'm going to take I'll
give you the easy answer and then I'll
then I'll negotiate with the hard part
the easy answer is of course there's no
like two-minute way of saying it there
isn't a two-minute way of say saying it
and part like part part part of the way
that both inevitability and especially
eternity work is chopping everything up
into small bits right so like if you
want to like you know you don't have to
admit you're doing this but if you want
it doesn't even matter if it's MSNBC or
or or CNN or or Fox right you could if
you watch any of them they break up
what's happening into such small bits
that nothing ever happens right Mitt
Romney ties his shoelace Mitt Romney
takes a step towards restaurant in New
York Mitt Romney lifts a fork
right Mitt Romney has first course
Donald Trump raises Fork you know like
every like like pixel by pixel you know
like and and so nothing ever actually
happens every story is developing
there's no developed story heading right
every story is always developing and
nothing ever actually happens in the end
and so my point is that like we have to
I think we do I mean I hate to sound
like a cranky old historian which I am
but we have to get away a little bit
from the I got to be able to do it in I
mean I do things in 180 characters all
the time or however many characters it
is and not without assistance but but
but but um but but but like we have to
get away a little bit from the we can
solve it that way because we can't right
like the the the the you know the long
the long form journalism right the
attention span that's part of some of
the things that I'm talking about
especially the factuality bits um you
can't get to fact to fact to factuality
without like longer longer exposure
longer attention spans a very
self-conscious you know approach to
approach to print I think um okay that's
the easy way out the the the harder part
is you know I I can't so so there at one
level like what I'm trying to say is
that any engagement with history whether
it's like Native American history which
you know is I I find increasingly
interesting you know or or or or
African-American history or especially
any history that's not your own right
like that's that's sort of important to
all of this but engagement with the
history that's not your history any
engagement of that sort is political in
the way that I'm describing because it
builds out the possibility of politics
right politics requires time and
somebody has to produce that time right
and people who think historically are
producers of time as opposed to
Consumers which other people are right
and again like that it's it's something
like that exactly what ideas you're
working for or like what kind of future
you see you know I don't know and I'm
not going to give you that I'm not I'm
not going to stand here and give you
that what I am going to say is that just
mechanically in order for there to be a
future like it's rich in possibility
there also has to be a pass which is
rich in possibility right and that and
to have that pass you have to there has
to be something like history so you know
look I'm not trying to solve everything
with this lecture either you know I'm
try I I as a historian like these are I
think these are things like we can do to
recognize patterns and try to head them
off like that's the that's the
catastrophe part you know and to to to
learn what one can do when very bad
things happen and then also to to get
get a certain toolbox right that's
already going pretty far I I can't I
can't go much further than
that
okay anything else oh who
there I'm stud American history and I
know this is a littleit outside of your
wheelous when you talked about um you
know watching out one party gradually
eroding the influence of all other
parties and uh different institutions
and paramilitary groups being licensed I
was wondering you had any about how
where we go from here plays out in a
country where we have a fragmentation
between the state and federal power and
we have a federal government that's
controlled by one party you also have
many states where one part is in control
on both sides of that spectrum and that
prevents both that that presents both
obstacles towards reform and it presents
the temptation to uh have this have you
know if you live in a state where you
believe that you know to take blue
States and make them almost Utopias of
what we might Envision to be ideal and I
don't know you you know based on your
historical knowledge how that might pan
out what to avoid what you look for in
this sort of layer situation between
federal and state
Authority okay so
yeah I'll give you some very general
because like if you've taken a class in
US history you're already you know way
ahead of me in terms of actual knowledge
but I mean at a at a no really it's been
a while and a lot of stuff has happened
in the meantime um but like the the the
federal system I think it's an excellent
point and when you know and when PE when
we talk about like the appropriateness
of some of the analogies I'm making it's
a very important point because one of
the things that happens in the 20s and
30s and so the Germans in 20s and 30s
had a lot of things that we have right
they had an educated population they had
export Le you know they had export-led
growth um they probably you know they
had better manners and longer attention
spans you know they had a lot of things
we had and and uh it's nodding with the
attention spans somehow here and um but
they also had the rule of law and they
were they were they were obsessed with
the rule of law and they had a federal
they had a federal system right and so
you you you you you watch those things
can go away is my point right so the
rule of law can be changed from the
inside um and and you can unify so I'll
give you the example of the police right
so the police in the United States are
sort of you know beautifully
spectacularly
decentralized um in Germany they were
fairly decentralized at the beginning
but they found a way to create command
structures which slowly embraced not
only all the police at a central level
but also the police plus the SS by by
the end you know by by by the end or you
by the around the time the war started
that had all been worked out into one
pyramid so that's something I would
watch I would be very alert for like I
gave the example of watch out for the
sort of the paramilitaries the guys with
uniforms who March in strange formations
and sort of are in the state not in it
right which in the US of today is like
it's a question of like what what
there's so many guns right and there are
so many various kinds of paramilitaries
the so for in our context it's like if
that starts to seem less disorganized
and less anti-stem and suddenly is Pro
system and more organized I'd watch out
for that but the other example like with
Federal with the federal system would be
does the center try to get all the
organs of power in into some kind of
pyramid right I would I would very much
watch out for that that's about as far
as I can go I mean I'm I generally tend
to think that the states are a very
useful like at this particular moment
they're a very useful barrier right when
you you know I don't know where you're
from but like some of my familyes in
California and like from there of course
the whole thing looks different if
you're in a big economy you know with
like with police forces which you don't
think are likely to do certain things
the whole situation might look different
than if you're in a little State like
like
Connecticut yeah like whether the I mean
I tend to think the blue State should
make the Utopias if that's because it it
it shows it shows what's possible it
expands The Horizon I mean not that
they're actually Utopias right I mean
but you know I tend to think that that
like the state like you know that states
do things and then and then some of
those things turn out not to be
disasters and then they become totally
normal right the example of like of um
of partnership right or you know Mar
equality like Massachusetts or whoever
does it and it turns out not to end the
world and that removes one of the big
arguments against it that it was going
to end the end the world right and then
it of becomes boring because you know
for Americans it's either in the world
or it's boring right and so so it kind
of became boring anyway I tend to think
that they should there they should be
Laboratories of policies because it
shows what's possible but that's as far
as I can go with that yeah I mean in my
negative mindset it's really like the
it's the police that I that I think
about the most you know because so when
I think about Germany right goes back to
Max's question you know I think about
like the police in in Breman who were
you know one day and breman's a nice
town you know one day they were
directing traffic literally and like
three days later they were in KY of
rounding people up to be shot at babiar
with no particular training nothing in
particular right there were people who
were trained there were people who were
ideologically motivated not these guys
particularly but they did it they were
all part of one command structure and
then once you got them into an
unfamiliar situation conformism kicks in
and then once they've done it they've
done it and they can't go back from
having done it and they do it again so
like it's it's the it's the police that
like that the fact that America's police
power is split up in all these kinds of
ways which I find
interesting okay I think I think the the
the the vs PO is uh is saying that we've
used up our time so maybe one more
question yeah you know Eastern and
Central Europe well what do these people
tell you about the election ofum do you
think would be changing for them with
the election of trump in that part of
Europe well so the first thing I would
say is
that it was people who work on Eastern
Europe whether they were EAS Europeans
themselves or just students of East
European politics who tended to think
that something like Trump was possible
um because you know because um these
these things partly because like if
you're an East European you have just a
broader sense of what's possible this is
one of the things that chess Mi says
with particular ruthlessness about the
about the Americans or about the West
that like we I think he uses the phrase
childishly naive but the idea that be
because things haven't happened to us
they're just not in our imaginary um and
and therefore we don't know how to react
to like the most fundamental things that
can happen like for example that one day
there are corpses on the street you know
that's just part of life that one day
their corpses on the street and the
Americans have no notion of what you
know so Easter being in Eastern Europe
at least until very recently involved
having this broader notion of what the
possible was but the other the other
thing is of course that there are very
few things in the Trump phenomenon which
are not present in some form or other in
Russia Ukraine Hungary or or or Poland
right I mean each of these like it's
just sort of kind it's one more case
which has a family resemblance to to the
other cases and those cases just
happened to come to come first so people
were less surprised right I mean in
Eastern Europe in Western Europe there
was there was much more like he's a joke
can't write down to the last minute he's
a joke it can't happen you know um how
do they think about it it depends who it
depends who I mean people who uh who who
who who who believe that their um their
future and or or their way of living or
even their life depends upon some kind
of Atlantic cooperation you know whether
it's NATO or whether it's a European
Union which has the Americans as a
friendly Outsider those people are very
concerned of course right very concerned
that this is the first American
President Who
um who who who who who who sees the EU
and NATO as being sort of superficial
irrelevant they should pay their own way
that's never happened before those
people are very concerned and you know
even like and and and the notion of a
European army or european structures
like that conversation has moved forward
very quickly in the last few few weeks
few weeks and months um some people of
course are are just are are in utter
despair because this goes back to thing
I was saying about like International
models it really does matter what
happens in more than we realize you know
the
Things become plaus things are plausible
or implausible depend on what happens in
other countries right so this was that
you would lose the us as a model right
which of course I mean let's not like
let's not you know for all the like for
all the Liberals for all the US has gone
as a model now right just I mean it's
gone just like Poland has gone for
Ukraine it's gone it's gone it's over um
it's a I mean it's it's many things it's
important you try to work with it and so
on but the notion that this is actually
like some kind of you know ideal
democracy that's you know that's gone um
it was I mean it was a lot of it was
gone even before the election actually
happened um because of the style of the
election and other things but so that's
you know that's that's quite sign and
people it's harder for people to live
without models right so in the next in
the next few months I think a lot of
what's going to be interesting to see is
how much the Europeans actually managed
to come up with a
European not so like anti-americanism
was always kind of a luxury like because
America was there like she can be as
anti-American as you want you know
because America's there right it's a
version of this like disruption thing
like sure you can be anti-American
because they're here anyway right now
that America is not there at least
morally and might not be there
politically and militarily might not
then anti-americanism is suddenly
irrelevant right it's gone basically
because no one has time for it it's
irrelevant what you now have to do is
sort of non- americanism right you have
to think of how you might manage these
things without without the Americans so
you know that's that's that's my basic
sense but I mean like there's a positive
side to this as well which I've been
feeling for months which is that my
friendships in Eastern Europe are you
know more resonant than they ever were
because these people are able to predict
things that are going to happen in my
country with like fantastic
perspicacity okay the I think the the
the dominant mood is that we've this has
been going on long enough yeah so thank
you very much for coming thanks for
[Applause]
[Music]
talking